good afternoon everyone welcome to this
after film awards session on editing and
I'm delighted to welcome our three
guests here this afternoon
whose body of work is both diverse and
quite brilliant and to my far right is
Hank Corwin and vice is Hanks second
BAFTA nomination for editing following
his earlier collaboration with Adam
McCauley on the big short I think it's
ready to get an editor who has produced
quite such a diverse body of work from
the frenetic world of of Oliver Stone's
films through to the more ruminative
philosophical work of Terrence Malick
amongst the films that Hank has worked
on is Natural Born Killers the horse
whisperer the new world what just
happened and songs a song
next to him is Tom cross and frenetic
he's another word that I would use that
captures the thrill of Tom cross is
stunning BAFTA award-winning work on
Damien Chazelle sophomore film whiplash
he received a second nomination for his
work again with Damien on la-la-land
and he's also had edited joy hostels and
the greatest showmen before
collaborating again with Damien and
receiving his third BAFTA nomination for
first man and finally to my immediate
right is Adam Gough Adam was an
editorial trainee on Alfonso Cuaron's
children of men then he was an assistant
editor on in Bruges the secret of
moonacre
Solomon came both parts of the Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows series
and he was nettle on bees make honey
before he returned to work with Alfonso
Cuaron on Roma gaining his first BAFTA
nomination welcome Thank You Adam let's
let's start with you and working with
Alfonso Cuaron as a co-editor I gather
you were working on another project
initially while the film was a filming
of Rome was happening yes so I got back
in sync with Alfonso a couple years
before Roma started so he was looking
for an editor and was doing a commercial
so
that was kind of my job interview so I
was in lined up to do whatever he was
doing next so I think Roma was the third
product of script that I read where I
didn't read the script wasn't giving us
great but the third project that he kind
of went through until it landed and what
he went into shoot so yes that was quite
daunting don't have going straight in
with that not cutting any long long form
with him and not really interviewing or
talking too much about the project and
how we were gonna work together apart
from like the one week we did short form
that it was rather relaxed considering
co-editing directing producing
cinematographer you know bit of
everything
it was quite intimate so we we cut in
Italy no interference really from
everyone just took our time to do it and
dealt with it in a relaxed manner and in
the initial stages of becoming involved
on Roma did you get notes from him or
conversations about what he was kind of
looking for no I had no idea what was
happening I had a brief outline of the
project as dailies came in each day I
was watching it for the first time
learning what was happening so I I
didn't know so um I was at that stage we
started everything that day one a
post-production but during production I
was just checking it technically doing
an assembly learning the footage so once
we sat down to start together I was up
to speed on everything which was needed
because I didn't have a script I don't
know what's going on Hank I mentioned
Adam McKay is previous from the Big
Short which you also edited and you've
you've had relationships with Oliver
Stone and Terrence Malick before I'm
just curious about the collaboration
that you had with Adam on voice
following on from the big short and did
you feel there was this sort of
symbiotic relationship you got where he
was going with it yeah no absolutely I
mean it you have to develop you have to
develop a sense of rhythm a language a
common language with your director and
once you do that it becomes almost
second nature you know I can I can
empathize with what Adam was saying you
know initially it can be a little bit
terrifying and also as an editor you
have to feel
safe you know you can't you can't feel
like you're in jeopardy if a cat goes
south and they do go south
and you know on Vice I mean the film
sometimes went on its side but I never I
never felt in jeopardy you know I'm
curious of your body of work and I'm not
to say that atoms work at all is like
Oliver Stone's but thinking about his
approach to his subject matter and then
looking back at Stone's films like
Natural Born Killers almost machine gun
fire editing at times taking on so many
different subjects and jumping around
between them when you came to work with
Adam on the Big Short
did he have a conversation with you
about sort of Oliver Stone and you and
your approach to editing actually he
didn't you know we just we just had a
meal and then he told me I was hired no
you know the thing is Oliver is very
visceral and his approach to things is
very visceral Adam is really
contemplative he's just brilliant
and like untry a life you have Terry
Malick who's he's a bit like a songbird
he's he's out there and and you know he
hears he hears frequencies that you
don't hear and they're all different Tom
thinking about first man
if whiplash is percussion and la-la-land
is melody this this film feels very much
posited between the two in a way again
it you have another ongoing relationship
with a director was this easier just
coming on board and and knowing that you
know how Damian works it seemed more
difficult somehow I mean it was it
always gets easier in that we early on I
you know I met Damian because we worked
on his short film version of whiplash
and we immediately kind of hit it off
and both of us our movie love
and we like a lot of the same movies and
that's that's how he communicates or a
lot of how he communicates he creates
these you know he's very he prepares
quite a bit and so you know either
through storyboards or animatics he
certainly does both of those things but
also through a list of reference films
and and those with each project we do
those that list gets longer and longer
but on whiplash for example his big
reference was Raging Bull he said he
wanted the drumming scenes to feel
brutal like the boxing scenes from
Raging Bull and so and I've had other
directors when I've worked on other
small projects before Damien that would
say I want this to be you know I really
want this to feel gritty like a 70s
movie or something and then the dailies
you get or nothing like that you know
but Damien is is is pretty close without
copying I feel like without merely
replicating so so when he says I want to
feel like this I have a good idea of
what I what I want what he wants it to
feel like so in that way our
communication just gets deeper and
deeper but again with each project the
list of movies gets deeper and deeper to
the point where I can't even get through
all of them you know but you know so on
on on la-la-land of course it was a lot
of musicals but it was also movies like
about Hollywood so there was always
things like Boogie Nights and it was it
was a lot about Los Angeles because it
was the movies supposed to be a love
letter to Hollywood in Los Angeles and
first man was was really he was really
inspired you know by a lot of cinema
verite documentaries like the Maysles
and frederick wiseman and and Panabaker
so we watched a lot of those movies in
particular we watched primary Robert
true documentary with cinema verite
cameras following around President
Kennedy and Bobby Kennedy and the movie
crisis same thing and that was really
key for the earthbound dramatic scenes
with with the family for the space
capsule missions he wanted to reference
things like Saving Private
United 93 wanted to feel this visceral
you know life and death you are there
kind of feeling and so so all that was
easy to kind of get I think the
difference between first man and his
other two movies is that he just he's he
he just shot so much film I mean
compared with what he did before he's
he's really great in terms of getting
what you need for the editing style that
he wants he can be very specific so he's
great about getting pieces so for
example on whiplash that was something
like it was a very small movie and it
was something like a 20 day shoot but
within those 20 days he had a full day
and this is like a three million dollar
or indie movie he had a full day just
for insert photography and I remember
the last scene and again this is like a
Sundance movie the last scene I had
camera setups that went in went around
the alphabet a couple times went into I
think CA and that's on like a little
indie movie and and I remember the
schedule was so tight on that movie that
I told my assistants cuz we had they
start shooting September and we had to
deliver a cut to Sundance in November
and we locked picture in December and I
said the good news guys is there's no
time to fire us but but so this so first
man you know things everything gets
bigger the schedule gets bigger the crew
gets bigger but he shot so much more
film you know he's shot we shot like 1.7
million feet of film and all these
different film formats and and he's very
demanding like he's very he just and
this this helps all of us in a way
because he takes us all along but he's
so ambitious and he has ambitious ideas
for the movie and what he wants to try
but also what was different about this
project is he shot a lot of he shot a
lot of it was all Vera Tay and it was
also I mean a lot of it like the action
scenes are very pre-planned in some ways
but but he always kind of was very open
to having a second camera third camera
grab things and in fact he shot two
weeks of rehearsals with Ryan Gosling
and Claire Foy and the child actors
to have them get comfortable with each
other he had them they were in full
makeup and hair and they had fully
dressed sets and he just put them in
that set and just had them play house
and then just followed them around with
a Veritate camera you know totally
improvised it was supposed to just be
tests you know and of course I wasn't
even on the movie when they shot the
test had i known how much of that
footage we were gonna use I would have
insisted on being there from the
beginning but so that this this movie
had a lot more of that sort of thing so
we did a lot more rewriting in the
editing room just one stay with you a
moment
I had the pleasure of talking with
members of the same team on first man a
short while ago and one of the things I
asked them that I think it's absolutely
unique about this film of the batch of
films I've seen the last few years it's
not a film that's for me is set in the
past it's very much a film that I feel
was filmed in the past filmed in that
moment when the action unfolds they do
it and part of that I think is down to
the editing style of the film there it's
a lot quicker these days unless you're
watching Romo but I find that really
fascinating that I just got this sense
of of watching a film that was made then
not now was that a discussion that you
had in terms of the Pennebaker
a little bit I mean just in that Damian
really wanted it to to feel like you
know he wanted to channel those movies
and so so definitely you know came my
way in terms of the editing but it was
also I mean I was really just taking
what was in the footage so Lina Sangren
is cinematographer you know shot a lot
of it he tried to shoot all of it very
tape but some of it again was very
improvised and and you know in the case
of scenes at home but also Mission
Control you know they would stage a lot
of these scenes like Mission Control
like one long stage play where every
person in Mission Control had scripted
dialogue and the cameras would just
follow people around like a documentary
and every take would be different and
and there would be these little
anomalies these camera things like focus
rack
snap zooms and pans and a certain sort
of messiness that that Damian and I
thought were really was really cool when
we saw that in dailies and thought we
could really use those things or that we
would be allowed to use them
you know and and that was different from
lala land and whiplash and and it's
funny because Lena's Sangren saw ruffcut
an early rough cut of the movie and he
talked me about it afterwards and he was
surprised that I had used some of the
stuff messiness messy camera move and
this and that and but he liked it but he
was surprised because I think when he
was shooting it you know he wasn't
merely trying to replicate Verte these
little things were just a means to an
end like he was really covering the
action like a documentary like you would
a documentary camera person it's just
that when I saw that stuff I thought
that was exciting I thought number one
you know the style of the movie allowed
for that so it just meant that we
actually could feature more performance
stuff that you might otherwise not be
able to use in other words if there was
something if the focus was soft or
something was messy it was still fair
game you know but also in certain scenes
like some of the press conference scenes
you know there was a way that that
Damian wanted those to be he wanted to
really feel the cuts like he wanted
those to feel like an attack on the
alarm strong and so there's a place
where we could use some of those things
of snap zooms and things just for
punctuation so it was a lot of fun but
it was it was different from the
previous adventures we had Hank come to
choose the word a precision I'm one of
the things that struck me when I saw
vice was the level of precision to the
whole film it was incredible how its
pieced together
but where's when I saw the big short I
thought okay I can follow this like I
can kind of understand how this was put
together I remember coming away starting
to have a headache thinking of how on it
is do you start to work on voice and put
this together
because you're jumping back and forth in
time you're working with fact you're
working with interpretation of facts
you're working with fictional I
elements of someone's life how much of
the script ended up being the finished
film in terms of the nonlinear order you
know Adam Adam pretty much had it
figured out we ended up we we ended up
experimenting moving things around but
you know ultimately for the way I look
at it cutting films is you really go
with the flow of of the material and you
know I'm sure these guys screen their
dailies and and take copious notes you
know I've got full of full of notes so
you know where the footage is you know
sort of what you're going to say if
there's any real precision it's strictly
accidental I'm sorry no no no yeah I
guess let's move up when I think of
precision in in terms of voice tempo the
the ability for the film to race along
at a hundred miles now then come to a
grinding halt and and and move a little
slowly with us then to pick back up but
again but you know the thing is on a on
a film okay this is this this gets very
deep there there very good audio fades
no but you know the thing is on a film
like this you well you you have the you
have the facts which have been vetted
and then you have the humane miss the
humanity and it's I we would think that
almost as emotional realism so you would
have you'd you'd you'd you'd have the
facts but they'd become overwhelming so
you'd have to you know you'd have to
feel where you you want it to slow the
film down and like for me I I love like
an ambiguity in characters and I I know
you had in your
there was there was huge ambiguity and
so you know you just feel your way
through it and we you know we had the
the luxury the dubious luxury of having
many test screenings so we would just
screen the film through other people's
eyes and it wouldn't be for it wouldn't
be for uh for notes or comments or
scores we would we would just feel the
film over and over and over and that was
that was one of the keys to getting this
film right I'll come back some elements
of the film in a moment but Adam we're
talking about tempo everyone knows that
Alfonso loves a long take Morphin not an
incredibly complex long take you came
onto this film with no idea of what the
script was you were being sent dailies
I'm just curious how you go from there
well it was quite easy to read when the
footage was coming in with the the
camera moves and the blocking of working
out where he wanted to go with it so it
wasn't that it was too much of a puzzle
to start with to build it it was really
kind of just finding that rhythm to
follow it so what Alfonso did on this
and it's great having an editor behind
the camera is he understood he wanted
like longer tales and handles and all of
his shots so he would leave the camera
rolling maybe up to a minute well after
the kind of the dialogue had finished
just let the scene play out and he would
let the actors kind of maybe ad-lib or
continue to live in the moment and just
let the camera roll so we had the
options of we didn't have to cheat
anything we had these like very very
long elements to kind of cut in and out
of sometimes minutes so I think that was
kind of the most challenging element of
finding that rhythm but the rhythm was
really was following the pace of the
footage like this it's being set in that
first shot with the water coming in so
you know you can feel the flow and then
the long camera pan around and then
following Claire at the house so it was
just trying to follow it elegantly and
not to break the
hello within that you'll see you're
still cutting it's just one of those
things I find really fascinating with
Alfonso looking back to children of men
and the extraordinary childbirth
sequence of still knowing when you need
to make that cut at the end and that's
the thing fascinates me we talk you just
mentioned the opening shot which is
stunning not only trying to work out
what we're looking at but then suddenly
seeing the reflection of the plane going
across the floor going across the sky as
you worked on your own on it and an
Alfonso was also working how much
freedom did you have to sort of play
around with things or did you guess if
when I was working on my own that was
just for me to learn the footage so day
one that's all now we start again from
scene one and just work through it so
it's really just to kind of understand
where we're going with it so the
challenge was the amount of shots that
he would be shooting so a good example
Mac's example is the scene in the hail
where Clio tell Sophia that she's
pregnant
he's shot that 60 times and that's a
free minute 45 shot so when I line all
those down that's three hours of dailies
for the same thing and there's all lots
of little differences in it as well so
he was still experimenting with the
tension within the family so because the
actors were getting sides each day he
would be giving different kids different
sides so they might have different bits
of dialogue because he was trying to
create this tension in the shot and
people would talk over each other so we
ended up with different options and
strong options so it was a
decision-making process of just finding
where we wanted to go in that and I
think just making that select at two
days in the cutting room of just
reviewing talking about it experimenting
sometimes we'd put a couple different
versions in and see how that would play
because you would find that it would
affect something else if we ever changed
a shot then we were then trawling
through scenes either side to make sure
that that rhythm would then follow it so
but then once we could have had that
built up it was just a moment of just
doing casters on it so having to tackle
it in long runs to make sure we could
have had that correct rhythm going
through
and going back to the Hale one actually
I only like realize this the other day I
was just looking at some of the bits
kind of putting some elements and the
last line of dialogue so when we've kind
of finished that scene where they just
relax and they settle it's about 12
seconds before we then cut to the next
scene so we're kind of just setting
these beats so we're trying to not make
any cut on comment just to let you then
take it in and just gently move along
Tom thinking about Damian's background
in music is his love of music and the
musicality of of the film's how much
does that play upon the the work that
you produce and then sort of the
conversations that come out of that with
with Damian quite a bit I mean Damian
his background is he was a competitive
jazz drummer so whiplash is kind of
based on his personal experiences I
don't think he had a teacher that
slapped him around but I think he had a
teacher who was pretty rough would play
kind of mind games but but I you know
besides me taking piano lessons and
studying a little violin I don't think I
could reach sheet music today to save my
life so I'm not a musician I'd like to
think I know what sounds good or what
sounds right but I'm definitely I'm not
a musician so I really defer to I always
defer to Damian's taste and judgment in
in that regard but I would say music
really plays a big part in the picture
editing or at least it did certainly in
whiplash but also Lalo land and also
first man we set up this kind of style
of working on lala land where our
composer Justin Hurwitz was in a room
next to my editing room we shared a door
and so as soon as I as soon as Damian
came in to start his director's cut
Justin started alongside us and in the
case of lala land you know he had to be
on early on to prepare all the music the
they were gonna film too he ended up
kind of doing the same thing on first
man I mean he worked out a lot of his
melodies and a lot of pieces during
pre-production and he would feed them to
Damion hundreds and hundreds of drafts
there might even be a thousand drafts I
don't know but he would bounce these
things to Damian and Damian would would
give him notes say no you know and
they'd go back and forth and so by the
time I started cutting I already had a
lot of his rough demos of Justin's music
and I always used those to inform how I
was cutting things and in the case of
some of the scenes like the lunar
landing
you know Damian had kind of a rough
animatic of that that I tried to follow
and it had the animatic was done with
storyboards and an archival footage for
picture and for audio it was just some
bare-bones sound effects and then
Justin's rough demo and so I would kind
of you know have that as is my pad to
kind of start with and as dailies would
come in we'd we'd kind of over cut and
kind of go from there and then once
Damian came in you know then then you
know we really that was very those
things end up being very very rough I
mean again Damian pre plans really well
but I always find that you know the
animatic and and just trying to copy
that it's always just a that's just a
starting point you know I was fine
cutting to an animatic in some ways it's
great in other ways I find it really
terrible because then I feel like I'm my
hands are kind of tied because I'm just
trying to match you know I'm just trying
to match a plan and it's always very
hard for me to match it because so many
things have changed you know when they
shoot it this oh this is this shot it's
supposed to be you spend a lot of time
trying to figure out is this shot in
dailies is this supposed to be this shot
and the animatic and it feels like it
takes so long to kind of get a straight
answer about those things and once you
put it together it always just is this
kind of mechanical thing you know that
doesn't really have any soul and so
but you do it knowing that it's just a
starting point and again it's it's a
little bit like what Adam is saying you
know that process that Daly's process is
is just a great way for you as an editor
to get to know the footage to organize
it the way that you know where you'll so
you'll know where to find everything and
so that's a lot of what it's like with
Damien but some music really you know
plays a strong part and certainly in
la-la-land but also in first man because
we were always we never had any other
for the most part we may have had one
piece of 10th music from another movie
but everything else was was rough demos
of Justin Hurwitz the score so we were
always temping with his music and from
the very beginning so I always had his
stuff and and we would go from there and
so because he's right next door he's
there every day if we stay till 2:00 in
the morning or 4:00 in the morning
Justin's often there too and it's kind
of a little bit like a television sitcom
where you know we just kind of opened
the door and sometimes people don't
knock they just open the door and say
hey do you want to you know do you want
to come take a look at this demo come
take a listen because I just changed it
or or the other way around where Damon
will just pop in and say Justin come in
here and look at this thing that we just
did and so it's very unlike other
projects I work on where the composers
come on a lot later and you know they're
they're a little bit of a slave to the
picture here there's a much more of a
back-and-forth and so I'm really cutting
to match the picture and in fact we had
a great music editor on the movie Jason
ruder but often you know Damien doesn't
want to since he has a musical
background often he just wants to work
out the music Edit in my room with me
you know cuz he knows what a tits he
likes and what else he doesn't so I find
that I end up executing a lot of these
music edits too you know and then once I
do these things
you know then that informs how we're
gonna recut picture you know so there's
there's a lot of like you know that
cycle of back and forth happen
constantly on first man
Hank thinking about the music for voice
BAFTA was lucky enough to have Nicolas
Patel here earlier today talking about
Beale Street and he also composed the
music I play he's composed music for
both of Adams films that you've worked
on how does that relationship work you
know it's it sounds very similar to what
what tom has going we're very close
we're close friends and what will happen
even before when I'm looking at dailies
I'll have them just come watch with me
well sometimes just plug his computer
into the board you know play me tones
and then Adam will come and we'll all
talk and Nikhil go off and he'll give me
sketches and I'll cut them in but you
know it's it's the most fantastic thing
to have the opportunity to work with a
with a composer right from the beginning
I'm spoiled I'm sure you are who I it's
it's the most awful thing to be
presented with music it's a fait
accompli after the fact you know so Nick
in in a sense as as Adam became
co-editors and you know we all became
sort of and I I this gingerly but we
were sort of Co composers on a very
limited level so with that in mind I
think one of the interesting challenges
advice that it succeeds with is
presenting a knockabout comedy of a frat
boy who decides to take himself
seriously in the first half and then we
suddenly encountered tragic local events
in the second humors still exists but
the humor gets much much darker as it
goes along and I just felt that both the
editing and the music played a
significant part in that and I was
wondering how how much of a challenge
was it to get that turn right around as
it shifts you know again it was it was a
matter of trial and error we wanted we
knew where we wanted to take the film
you know it
but there you know initially initially
it it it felt a little flamboyant and
then there was you know there became
this this almost profound reverence for
power you know and and and we were we
were almost afraid of it as you know as
the team working on the film but Nick
you know Nick's music actually helped
guide it you know and he because he he
created musical arcs that we were able
to plug into a shifting from time back
to tempo
just thinking about it's it's such an
epic film in scope Roma and again light
like vice and very much like the first
man that the shifts are quite
extraordinary through and could you talk
a little bit about the conversations
that you had with Alfonso the lead-up to
the riot scenes of what you're going to
ask me about my score the lead-up to the
riot scene for that there was it was
getting just building it as it kind of
ran in that first pass on it wasn't
actually too difficult where it started
getting tricky was when we were working
on the rhythm with the vocals in the
background so we had these great
recordings of crowd chanting and then we
would revisit that scene in the build-up
where we were kind of with those chants
we were going between them trying to set
some geography outside for the group
setting the scale so that was probably
one of the more challenging elements in
that build-up there but I for Rome
anyway I see everything kind of in
movements almost like an opera so part
of this cut goes from them arriving in
their car all the way up to the birth so
I see that almost as one rhythm as it
would be so that the the the car is kind
of shots probably getting slower but
we're building tension that are using
sound kind of all the way up to the to
the birth and then never seen the I
personally just guess
to know about and III don't know if they
were alternate shots to this but the
scene at the beach it is one of the most
extraordinary shots fed anyone who's
seen the film you're you're watching
someone watching people drowned possibly
drowning and manul it still makes me
incredibly nervous thinking about that
of how I felt while I was watching that
sequence was that decision made right
the beginning that is the shot we're
going for or with their multiple
perspectives initially that's all they
had
so that was actually an easy one to edit
because the day before there was a yeah
that's all they know no the Dave's a
great singer the date that they built
appear going out into the sea that they
kind of had the track on another camera
on a crane would go out with it and
there was two days before there was a
storm and it washed it away so they had
they were in a rush to rebuild it and in
that rush it didn't they didn't set it
well so it kept the camera kept D
railing so we have one complete shot so
that was yeah it was kind of easy that's
fantastic yeah oh I can't the birds in
at the beginning because we did have
another shot that you know a few that
did start there's none that made it to
the enemy I mean there was just one take
yeah that was an easy day at the office
just cut off the slates cop in the birds
and you're done job done okay Adam we're
gonna erase that part of the tape we're
gonna go back and you're gonna give us a
really complex reason for how this
happened we're all gonna think how
brilliant that is all CG everyone's seen
footage of a lunar landing and yet just
to still have that thrill in a fiction
film of recreation of that again the
same people were talking earlier about
the lengths they went to to get that
right sound but once all those shots had
been put together it is an extraordinary
sequence can you can you talk a little
bit about the challenge of actually
putting all that together well the I
think the big challenge in general for
that for the whole movie really was how
can we show the audience
things that they haven't seen before you
know how can we offer something dramatic
and we offer something emotional that
the audience is going to feel and that
they can invest in and that they haven't
seen before because I think the the
thing that we knew we would have to
fight is the iconography you know or
we'd have to work with it but we could
not merely just offer up Neil Armstrong
the icon we had to offer some of his
humanity we had to offer very personal
and intimate things that that people are
normally not privy to so I think for the
moon that was that was one of the
biggest ingredients as to is to find a
way to show things that that people
hadn't seen before and so people you
know I mean most people know images or
footage of Neil Armstrong climbing down
the ladder and make taking his first
step we knew that we would have to show
that because we owed that to the story
but you know a big part of it was okay
now can we go off on this other moment
and spend time with Neil Armstrong alone
where which really really did happen
there's some speculation as to did he
really do this thing that he did on the
moon we don't know that's kind of
speculation but we do know that he did
spend a certain amount of time alone
standing at a crater where he was off
radio comms and where he was away from
Buzz Aldrin and though that was a moment
that that Damian and the screenwriter
Josh singer really wanted to dig into
because then they felt like if if we
could somehow let the audience get into
Neil Armstrong's head a little bit or at
least to show this private moment that
they might begin to have an idea of what
he might have been feeling which i think
was something really important to Damian
so so we you know we leaned into the
subjective storytelling and what made
that easier was was the IMAX photography
so you know we had kind of set up this
thing this first-person kind of style
earlier and just right from the
beginning and the x-15 but so
we carried that forward in the Gemini 8
sequence where we leaned heavily on
these point-of-view subjective shots
where you would see things through the
alarm Strong's eyes he's approaching the
chimney capsule in IMAX we could you
know the the the resolution of the image
kind of allowed us to kind of hold on
those shots and slow down and and invest
in them more because you could really
there was more to look at in the picture
you know you could really focus on the
grain the fine grain of the soil and you
could you know you could you could hold
on that shot of the gloves climbing down
the rungs of the ladder because you
could really see the stitches and the
gloves and it just kind of invited us to
hold things longer and so in that way we
could kind of double down on the
subjective you are their style where you
know hopefully the audience is feeling
like it's there you know it's their step
that they're taking on the moon and once
you kind of get into that headspace our
hope was that we could kind of pivot to
this more emotional thing where we start
having these flashbacks and he starts
seeing images of his family and all of
that by the way is is he's not really in
the script that's stuff that's culled
from this 16 millimeter Verity footage
rehearsal footage and that's just
something we played around with in the
editing room I think this is something
that that all three films that are so
different have in common is they each
take on an incredibly large issue
whether it's a geopolitical situation in
Mexico in the early 1970s the lunar
landing and as as Christian Bale alluded
to the Antichrist and yet they they all
three films drill down and end up being
incredibly intimate and and deeply
personal Hank I just I just want to ask
you but the thing that in many ways
personalizes the the story of Dick
Cheney is the humor that comes out of a
film and I don't want to spoil it for
anyone who hasn't seen it but there are
a number of elements a an interesting
appearance of film credits reference to
Shakespeare and we find out
someone is quite late in the film where
we didn't even realize him knowing that
certain things were cut down people
talked about that the locker room scene
with Kristen Bell with his shirt off I'm
just curious what were those things that
just just worked straight away and you
knew that you you had them because they
come out as quite big surprises
surround the film the the credit
sequence was was actually very well
planned out the locker sequence locker
room the is it was also very well
planned out there wasn't much room there
for spontaneity Adam had Adam had
actually thought this stuff but there
was there was a real balance between the
seriousness of it and the and the comedy
Adamek Adam comes from an improv world
you know so he'll shoot many many takes
just having having his actors go in many
different places so it became a very
subjective thing you know how what is
funny what is not funny and well that's
that's that's pretty much it if you
haven't seen Vice it's still showing in
cinemas
I know Romo is available on Netflix but
there are two or three cinemas still
showing it in London do not watch it on
streaming first watch it in the cinema
there we go and you can see first man
now it's been released on DVD and
blu-ray
thank you very much the BAFTA for
organising this event but most of all
can you please join me in thanking our
guest today
[Applause]
you